aujourd'hui vous en doutez sur les
plateaux de tournage l'image de lino
ventura était évidemment dans tous les
esprits il faut dire que le comédien
avait tourné plus de 70 films aux côtés
des plus grands réalisateurs parmi eux
claude sautet qui est avec nous en
direct aux côtés d' hervé brusini hervé
tout à fait henry on vient justement de
voir une image de larmes à gauche un
film tourné en 1965
mais la première rencontre entre claude
sautet et lino ventura c'est 1960 ces
classes tout risque est-ce que ça n'a
pas été une sorte de révolution dans
votre vie claude sautet ou est
absolument seul qui causaient depuis 56
et la mer avec le scénariste abrupte sur
le projet de la tournée il avait tourné
un film avec isabelle pouvait lâcher et
moi les peuples et pas tellement envie
de vous étiez assistant
oui il arrive et j'aurais il m'a appelé
je sais très bien entendu j'ai vu tous
les films et il m'a dit est ce que tu
décides la journée ou pas si ça vient
vous demander de franchir le pas et je
suppose des pourquoi amélie écoute linge
à l'eva de données je vais devoir me dis
alors j'ai rien à dire l'île depuis un
point sur les matins ou non alors
évidemment je suis le chapitre j'ai dit
oui et je me suis fait ses classes tous
risques et c'est vrai moi je lui
absolument tout autre jour et je me fais
mes lancers n'zi mais propulsé on peut
presque dire que si vous êtes en train
de tourner ici ce soir c'est un peu
grâce à l'inserm on off et évidemment ce
qui était le lieu était très dur et en
plus que des sorties ne pas marcher à
l'époque et il n'a en marche et que deux
ambulances et deux ans plus tard et
quand un film c'est dur et sombre
il était là mais table meurtri qui est à
la base du projet vie n'est pas le
succès milliards après le classique mais
et puis j'aime un second cd tellement
donné l'un l'autre vers ce film que
langer crise que j'ai fait car j'ai eue
avec lui après gens voulant faire
d'autre mais il a disparu
ah bon ambiance passion viennent pour
trouver
monsieur le noir vous vous êtes
ingénieur du son vous avez tourné à deux
reprises avec lino ventura remis un
papillon sur l'épaule le spf toile
alors est ce que il était parce qu on le
comparait souvent à un gamin et on
disait que gabin lui aimé qu'on le
registre alors qu'il parlait pas c'était
la même chose pour lino absolument une
aventure à parler très très bas enfin
modérément bas mais de toute façon il
était très très consciencieux que quand
il y avait un petit problème il disait
je vais parler plus fort pour telle
prise et ils savaient très bien et en
plus on pouvait le mettre des micros
cravates comme j'ai moi-même et vu ça
c'est très léger embonpoint ça passait
très bien vivre qu'un problème qu'est ce
qu'ils faisaient sur les plateaux
c'était quelqu'un qui était toujours là
et il y avait une marotte qui les lui il
a vu une marotte et peu de gens le
savent a par les techniciens qui l'ont
fréquenté ces les mots croisés et dès
qu'il dit est un plateau où il allait
s'installer dans un coin il faisait des
mots croisés et demandez aux gens qui
l'entouraient de l'aider parce qu'il fut
difficile définition qui comprenait pas
qui comprenait pas qu'il n'arrivait pas
à trouver il la ferait sens voyez henry
le souvenir et là tout à fait présent
les anecdotes sans boules sont là et je
peux vous dire qu'il ya là aussi
derrière trois jeunes acteurs
il y à vincent lindon daniel auteuil et
puis il ya aussi qui dorment mort
sandrine bonnaire et bas qui n'ont pas
voulu parler parce qu'ils ont dit que
pour eux c'était un exemple la vie lino
ventura qu'il il
il voulait mener gérer leur vie d'acteur
comme celle de ceux de lino ventura dans
la discrétion
merci antennes d'or